faut s'arrêter là avec les saveurs
mélusine vous êtes tous mobilisés à ses
messages qu'on peut trouver sur les
réseaux de cette façon de le faire pour
les prédateurs d'approché d'aider des
jeunes en appâtant et en les amenant
vers des buts chose sûre que sur les
réseaux si beaucoup plus simple
d'approché des adultes et parfois les
adultes qui approche des enfants moi je
le vois souvent même moi quand j'étais
plus dans l'équipe a offert deux manches
et par des gens plus âgés que moi
j'étais d'ailleurs suivi par un vieux
monsieur qui me suivaient qui savent
exactement où j'allais je pense que
c'est important de par ce documentaire
ou autres de parler de ça et de me
sentir dans les comptes
donc soyez vigilants sur les réseaux
effectivement il des choses très bien
sûr les hommes il faut être très très
prudent surtout quand on a 14 16 que 16
ans là on est on est on est on est
fragile on peut se faire avoir par
madame sont beaucoup plus malins qui
sont de vrais prédateurs ils sont très
intelligents et prendra d'ailleurs que
ces images sur son mode opératoire des
30 janvier 2018
écoute ça va bien côté promet sinon je
suis tombé et me suis pas louper comme
on dit donc j'espère c'est ira mieux
donc la très soudé ce qui lui arrive et
voilages et comment es-tu tomber tu tbc
il fait j'ai bêtement glissé sur du
verglas je me suis ouvert le front est
dans la chute je me suis tordu le zizi
donc patronat en gros j'ai fait wow ça
crie cascades fin ça me paraissait déjà
très gros 2
je suis mais c'est un déo gags le truc
c'est possible oui ça crie cascade c'est
arrivé il ya longtemps
ça a dû être douloureux il me dit il ya
une semaine
et oui vraie cascade à la vidéo gag ben
oui assez douloureux quand même sept
points de suture et mon truc de garçons
tordu sur la gauche
je pense qu'il y aura une trace sur le
fond car c'est quand même chaud bah
écoute oui je veux bien qu'on très bon
là c'est le front est là dont benjamin
cela c'est une sacrée cicatrices quoi et
juste après
je sais pas si attention voilà c'était
donc hier soir